I'm gonna get right into the review but
first a word from this public service
announcement dedicated to the guy who
sat behind me during this movie who
wouldn't shut the [ __ ] up you're going
to burn in a very special level of Hell
a level they reserved for child
molesters and people who talk at the
theater you will be going there after
this life God guy he was stoned in his
defense that was clear about halfway
through hustlers so hustlers is not
about that magazine you used to have to
steal from your dad's drawer do we
remember God it's all digital now paper
porn hustlers is based on a true story
so we don't really know where the
[ __ ] ends and the real story begins
or vice-versa but it's about this group
of ladies who work in this strip club
and then times are hard after the
economic crash so they're like what do
we do we're gonna start hustling and
then illegal stuff and then more illegal
activity and then it gets out of control
and here we go we have ourselves a
scandal the main star the movie revolves
around constants whoo of crazy rich
Asians Fame but yes the scene stealer is
as you have heard Jennifer Lopez gonna
get that right out the gate gonna give
props JLo crushes it right when you meet
her you know she she's the matriarch
she's the one she's like everyone's
looking to her for guidance she's
clearly the leader she just has that
leadership quality she owns every scene
she's in like every scene is her scene
and everyone else is just visiting and
when the hustle is going down we'll call
it the second half of the movie I was
really entertained I don't I just I like
seeing crime I mean not that I like
crime to happen but once it has happened
it's a story to be told I like the story
being told and that's the thing this
movie has going for it this story is a
really interesting story again based on
a true story so I don't know where the
real story ends and the [ __ ] begins
but the story is really fascinating but
the fascinating part is in the second
half of this movie the first half is a
lot of build-up and I get why it's
build-up because you have to see that
characters you have to be introduced to
the characters there are trials their
struggles their family dynamic why
they're led to do what they're about to
do just felt like it dragged on a bit
like if they condensed the first half of
the movie when it's all going down the
big schemes are going down they could
have concentrated on more of what was
more or less mention
in the second half some girls start
their own little crime ring you should
have shown more of that more conflict
that comes with that had to lend itself
to some good tension rather than a
passing phrase and then now we move on
JLo carries the first half and then the
hustle carries the second half but I
would have liked to have seen more of
that it would have liked to have seen
more of the hustle because that's why
we're here it's the name of the game
it's actually the name of the movie
that's kind of tough this movie just it
feels a little choppy like this movie
was supposed to be a three hour long
epic but in the end it doesn't lend
itself to quite being a three hour long
epic it felt like it's not Goodfellas
you don't have the Joe Pesci being made
moment or anything like that but it does
feel choppy like it's like they have
these little tick marks like alright we
need that that that that in there but we
don't have enough time to really flush
all of it out but we still need it in
there I want to give the director props
in terms of use of audio a lot of people
you know a lot of times the visual
aspect the visual appeal that gets all
the shower and the audio kinda gets left
behind so this movie has a couple of
audio tricks that were used actually
they made the scenes more impactful than
they would have been had those audio
tricks not been used it's one scene the
audio goes out entirely that's when I
found out guy behind me talking the
entire time was stoned
she was like all going out or something
oh my eyes he's so he's high because
that's something a high person would say
when a brilliant use of an audio trick
was used just now but the scene was
really cool as were a couple other
scenes of audio techniques I really
appreciated that so not denying Jennifer
Lopez completely crushes it in this
movie not denying the fact that the
story is actually an interesting story
that I'm glad as told he's like oh this
movie feeling like there's something
wrong with me because everyone at TIFF
was going it was alright there's a part
of me that feels like this tried to be
Molly's game but not quite Molly's game
the movie had a solid second half when
it picked up at the first half I just
felt a little bored and it's like the
hustle was cool but not the flow I'll
say in the end this movie would have
been a better time if I were drunk yeah
now it's a party maybe if the guy was
[ __ ] talking behind you I feel like I
can compartmentalize the two that guy
did not help love she's truly is gonna
burn in hell buy some hustlers have you
seen it what do you think about it are
you with all the hype that's come out of
Toronto International Film Festival if
or what's your favorite movie involving
a hustle of some sort whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and know the beginning of the Dark
Knight that that's not applicable this
time that's a straight a bank robber
it's not
actually the other bank robbers got
hustled by the Joker whatever as always
if you liked what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]